we've been drawing analogies between i
guess we could say traditional
multiplication or scalar multiplication
and the first one we drew is when you
have traditional multiplication you
multiply one times any number and you
get that number again and you could view
one as essentially the identity the
identity number or this is the identity
property of multiplication you multiply
one times any number you get that number
again and that essentially inspired our
thinking behind having identity matrices
that hey maybe there are some matrices
that if i multiply it times some other
matrix
i am going to get that matrix again and
you've probably shown for yourselves
that you can do it in either way you
could have some matrix times
times an identity matrix and
get that matrix again
now if these if this if matrix a right
over here is a square matrix then in
either in
in either situation this identity matrix
is going to be the same identity matrix
but if matrix a is not a square matrix
then these are going to be two different
identity matrices depending on depending
on the appropriate dimensions
now let's see if we can extend this
analogy between traditional
multiplication and matrix multiplication
we know that there's another special
number in traditional multiplication and
that's a zero
so we know that zero times anything is
equal to
zero or anything times zero is equal to
zero
so what would be the analogy if we're
thinking about matrix multiplication
well it would be some matrix that if i
were to multiply it times another matrix
i get i guess you could say that same
zero matrix again
and that is what we call it we call it a
zero matrix so if i
take some matrix a
and essentially if i multiply times one
of these zero matrix or if i multiply
one of these zero matrix matrices times
a i should get a
i should get another zero matrix and it
depends on the dimensions you might not
get a zero matrix with the same
dimensions it depends what the
dimensions of a are going to be but you
could imagine what a zero matrix might
look like for example if a
is
one two three four what's a zero matrix
that i can multiply this by to get
another zero matrix
well it might be pretty straightforward
if you just had a ton of zeros here
when you multiply this out you're going
to get this you take the dot product of
this row and this column zero times one
plus zero times three is going to be
zero you keep going zero zero zero
zero
if we had
if we had a
and just to make the point clear let's
say we had a
matrix one two three
four five six
five six so over here what does we want
to multiply this times let's see in
order for the matrix multiplication to
work
my zero matrix has got to have the same
number of same number of columns is this
one has rows so it's got to have
it's got to have
it's got to have two columns
but i could make it have three rows so
it could look like this zero zero zero
zero
and i encourage you to multiply these
two pause the video right now and see
what you get
well when you multiply them let's think
about it
so the top left entry so this is let me
just write the dimensions this is a 3 by
2 matrix this is a 2 by 3 matrix
so
we know that we have valid matrix
multiplication going on right over here
same number the number of columns in the
first matrix is equal to the number of
rows in the second one and we also know
that the resulting product is going to
be a three by three matrix
so it's going to be a three by three
matrix and i'll leave it up to you to
verify that all the entries here are
going to be
all of the entries here are going to be
zero and it makes sense you you could go
through the math but you can see well
you just every time you're multiplying
say
this row
by this column to get that entry well
you just have zero times one plus zero
times four to get that zero there but
the whole point of showing you this
example is we have one zero matrix
multiplying by this being multiplied by
this matrix right over here and then we
get another zero matrix but it has
different dimensions